on savait que si on gagnait ce match on
faisait le grand chelem on était habité
par sa 23 mars 1968 tournoi des cinq
nations l'équipe de france de rugby
n'est qu'à une victoire de gagner le
premier grand chelem de son histoire
mais pour ça il va falloir battre le
pays de galles chez lui à cardiff devant
55000 spectateurs ça va être une partie
terrible et le parti basé sur la force
basé sur la puissance sur la volonté sur
l'abnégation à l'époque jo maso était
titulaire côté français aujourd'hui 54
ans plus tard il revient sur ce match
quel paradoxe alpes par rapport par
rapport à
trop loin destination maintenant ce que
d'abord y avait que ces nations l'italie
n'était pas encore éviter et qu'on joue
et que quand on lit britannique pour
avoir un résultat probant et majuscules
fallait qu'on gagne ce match alors
ollier ta langue et où aller mais on n
est pas une une pression supplémentaire
parce qu'il ya une page toute la
médiatisation qui en cas actuel pour
francs contre la france respire emma 9 à
3 c'est la mi temps entre joueurs aussi
dit que maintenant il fallait mettre une
pression supplémentaire sur l'adversaire
le car a été très très bon et on savait
que sa liste se jouait de voir dans la
conquête et ça paye seconde période la
france passe devant grâce à deux essais
avec un coeur admirable les avants
français supporter tout le poids de la
bataille mais la marge reste mince il
leur faut accentuer leurs attentes à
coup de sifflet final 14 à 9 c'est
historique la france remporte le premier
grand chelem de son histoire dans ma
carrière cet honneur un moment
incontournable et qui a marqué qu'à
marquer ma carrière bien sûr avec
d'autres matches mais celui-là était le
plus important toute cette foule qui
rappe sur le terrain tous les français
qui étaient étaient là le sable sont
arrivés sur le terrain pour faire la
fête avec avec nous alors à l'heure
actuelle c'est impossible voilà sur des
dernières images de cette foule en
délire regardez les penser un peu aux
vestiaires couverts de boue
ayant gallois gallois qui le lie à face
meilleure équipe du monde révèle cigale
versés ravive ici pour tous en 2022 54
ans plus tard la france va tenter de
gagner son dixième tournoi du grand
chelem
le dernier relève date de 12 ans ça veut
dire que maintenant on va on va pouvoir
renouer avec le succès j'espère parce
qu'on a une belle équipe de france jeune
et très souvent rennes je trouve
[Musique]